il rit et s'amuse à la fête de pourim
difficile d'imaginer que ces enfants ont
fui un pays en guerre début mars ils ont
été évacués de leur orphelinat juifs à
odessa en ukraine et commence à peine à
retrouver un semblant de normalité
grâce notamment aux rabbins qui les a
accompagné jusqu'en allemagne je vois
que émerger et des bonnes choses en plus
la fête de pourim célèbre la survie du
peuple juif face aux persécutions un
rituel joyeux qui prend cette année une
toute autre dimension pour mendy wolf
dont l'arrière grand père avait fui
l'allemagne nazie
s'il était vivant de nos jours et qu'il
voyait que les juifs d'ukraine fut les
russes pour aller à berlin et ils sont
accueillis à bras ouverts avec de l'aide
venant de toutes parts il serait enfin
je ne sais pas je ne peux pas expliquer
il centaines d'orphelins de desa ont
rejoint berlin mais aussi des mères
célibataires et des adolescents qui ont
laissé une partie de leur famille
derrière eux
honnêtement je suis heureux mais au fond
de moi je pense ce jour à cette guerre
j'y pense tout le temps
j'aime bien être ici mais c'est mieux à
la maison c'est toujours mieux d'être
chez soi
contraint de prendre la route de l'exil
des milliers de juifs ont déjà quitté
l'ukraine pour rejoindre israël mais
aussi l'allemagne et sa communauté juive
russophone installé dans le pays depuis
la fin de l'ère soviétique
le centre religieux qui accueille les
enfants se préparent à l'arrivée d'un
nouveau convoi avec 150 réfugiés à son
bord tous ces gens sont complètement
traumatisés mais nous pouvons désormais
les accueillir en allemagne et le fait
qu'il puisse revenir dans ce pays 80 ans
après l'avoir fui le fait que
l'allemagne soit désormais un refuge
pour les juifs
c'est un signal très fort
ici tous espèrent toutefois retrouver un
jour au dessin ou une ville empreinte de
culture juive près de la moitié des 38
juive de la cité portuaire ukrainienne
seraient déjà partis à l'étranger